who's gonna be the next bachelor
bachelor nation already as their fix but
first we have got the back-up finale to
get through tonight and tomorrow and
only we've got your exclusive sneak peek
I have three amazing men standing in
front of me that makes this hard for me
because I'm not just breaking somebody's
heart breaking though Hannah in tears
heartbroken tonight she'll send one man
home after that the decision only gets
harder me this is why you don't date two
people at the same time my heart gets
broken a lot for a lot of different
reasons
and while we wait to see if Hannah
actually finds happiness fans are
already campaigning hard for the next
Bachelor the frontrunner so far include
two of Hannah's final three pilot Peter
and contractor Tyler I think Tyler is
the cutest thing ever
so if he doesn't get chosen I could see
him being the bad Bush oh so hot yeah
Kaley Cuoco is a fan but Tyler has some
big competition from Big Mike we did our
own poll on Twitter and the two are
pretty close still the men of Hannah
season have one clear pick who's your
pick for bachelor Mike I would say
overall razor in tonight if chosen the
Air Force vet would be the first
african-american bachelor in 24 seasons
of the show but will likely have to wait
for an announcement until after bachelor
in paradise
Mike will be there and fun fact two of
the last three bachelors came straight
from the sands of Mexico to the bachelor
mansion I try to be myself the entire
summer there are so many fun stuff that
you guys anything to see I'm stupid and
goofy it's about time that's all I'm
just disappointed they missed their
chance with me
[Music]